حقيقه يعني الاوضاع مثل ما تحدثنا يعني
البنيه التحتيه هي اصلا تعرضت لدمار على
مدى عشر سنوات تعرضت للقصف تعرضت لالي
اصلا هي مدمره بشكل جزئي او هي غير
مدينه بالشكل الكافي حتى تتحمل الزلازل
الانهيار هذا العدد الكبير من المباني رغم
بعد المناطق شمال غرب سوريا عن المركز
الزلزال في كهرمان مرعش حوالي 300 كيلو
متر 350 كيلو متر هذا بسبب عمليات القصف
السابقه التي تعرضت لها هذه المناطق حاليا
فعليا الفرق تقوم بكل ما عليها حتى نستطيع
ان ان نقدم استجابه للكافي ولكن
يعني انا لن اقول ولكن تركيا كدوله كبيره
طلبت مساعده دولي في الاستجابه للزلزال
فايضا نحن كمؤسسات ايضا تعرضت لتقليص كبير
بالدعم خلال السنه الماضيه وبدايه هذه
اكيد ستكون هي غير قادره على
الاستجابه بشكل كامل بسبب اغلاق كثير من
المراكز الطبيه اغلاق كثير من المستشفيات
بالفتره الماضيه
الفرقنا حقيقه الان تعمل طاقتها حتى نقوم
باستجلاب اليات المدنيين حتى نستثمرها في
عمليه الاسراع نحن اليوم كفرق دفاع مدني
مسابق الزمن حتى نستطيع ان قال اكبر عدد
ممكن من المدني من تحت الانقاذ